welcome or not welcome michael yeah
[Applause]
i interview celebrities all the time are
you ready
[Music]
welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is michael yo and this podcast has
made three million dollars no no not not
quite close 225
446 dollars see see see not a bad guess
but
you know it's okay though you know like
i i want to like aim higher yeah and i
want to make great things happen so
maybe by the end of the podcast it would
make three million three million yeah
maybe
we need something to sell oh yeah
but you know what we got uh we started a
patreon
right yeah and i'm half black and asian
so i'm very in right now yeah like
ambiguous is the way to go i can be in
anything right cool and i'm
non-threatening there we go okay well
you know what if you want to see uh want
more info our patreon is down below in
the description you know when you walked
in i gotta say you had the nicest just
like look like really yeah your your
characteristics like your your facial
structure and everything you're just so
smiling are you attracted to me
are you are you hitting on i'm not
oh you know what that's interesting you
brought that up so so i uh
i passed out on an airplane this is a
crazy story so i'm i got food poisoning
i was flying from austin texas to here
and i got food poisoning and i was on
the window seat and i got up and i'm and
i passed the two people and all i
remember is taking two steps
and i woke up
and a guy had my legs over my head and
he was looking through my legs and he
goes are you okay and i was so confused
i go am i i have no idea so i passed out
in the middle of the aisle of a plane
and i landed between two nurses
like each my head fell in between two
nurses on the aisle and it was the
craziest i was out for like 45 seconds
on a plane in the middle of that what
happened food i i guess the i was
dehydrated food poisoning i wasn't
taking in liquids yeah and i just
finished performing like five shows so i
was exhausted i guess and i always take
the first flight out and
i you know what i i i don't sound morbid
but i always think about how death would
feel like and that's what it's like
because you i don't i'm just two nurses
standing over you yeah yeah
but you're just out you don't know
you're out until you come back and that
i mean it was the weirdest thing that
i've never been knocked out or passed
out but it was something man it was
crazy it was crazy holy and so but what
does that have to do with the ring oh so
when i fell
i was just trying to shift gears no when
i fell the ring came off and went under
like and i didn't know did you get it no
because i never knew i didn't have it on
because i was so out of it until i
landed it i was gone so while we're
trying to get uh i told and also another
reason the ring i have a um
what's it called uh my finger locks up
because of my ring jammed into my nerve
because i slap i sleep on my hand
and so i have trigger finger because of
the ring so i have to get a plastic one
now so we're looking for that so my wife
yeah i had a gold one but now i have to
get a plastic now what do you think
about jack wearing a ring you wearing a
ring
wow jack usually wears a ring on his
ring
finger on my right hand on the right
hand yeah and i said that's bad if he's
dating you shouldn't be wearing a ring
especially there you should be wearing
this i'm not i'm searching you know what
i mean
so you're a player no i'm not no you're
a player certainly not no no okay far
from it i am searching at the moment you
know looking for my lucky lady okay and
i wear a ring of my favorite musician so
who's that rex orange county is okay
yeah yeah yeah i could just wear a ring
yeah he it was like part of his merch
it's weird right so you just because you
like him you wear a ring i like yeah
yeah okay yeah and
okay yeah i like it that's weird it's
fine you know i think it's it's pretty
normal you wear a ring too right yeah
but i'm married
i'm married and i went down to the day
we're both wearing rings what if someone
wore a ring that said jack selby on it
that's pretty how do you feel about that
on honored i would be honest yeah
honestly it says his name on it too
no it's just it's it's just a logo it's
just a logo okay yeah yeah hey you know
what good for you yeah guys maybe i
should cut in here yeah we should say
who michael joe is yeah and how the heck
we met him so grant take it away
me okay you take it away i'll take it
away so michael yo is a comedian um i
the first time i ever saw him uh was on
youtube from agt and my first reaction
was me and my girlfriend at the time
which is now my wife we were sitting
there we were looking through all the
auditions and it was during the um
pandemic time and we saw this comedian
go on and we were like we looked at each
other and we're like dang comedians have
it tough this year because there are no
crowds so imagine going up to a stage
performing uh and not having a bunch of
people laugh
so that can sound pretty intimidating
but aside from that michael i believe
also does shows here in vegas around the
country
um i believe did you have a show on
sirius yes i have a show on siriusxm uh
it's a radio show it's on pop2k so we
play like britney spears backstreet boys
oh cool all that fun stuff and then uh
have a new tv show uh on apple coming
out called amber brown where i play
ex-husband so that's july 20 who's that
huh who's that amber brown yes it's a
fictional character and i play her dad
she's the daughter so and my wife is
sarah drew who is on grey's anatomy or
was and she was uh i forgot her name on
grey's anatomy but she was a big deal on
grey's anatomy but she plays my wife and
yeah so a struggle of me getting back
into their life and she's already
engaged so and it's a family show and
it's on apple so that's huge so that's
gonna be fun yeah have you always been
funny no like did you grow up and like
you're not funny i'm not funny like my
friends
i know but i'm not funny in real life
i'm funny on stage
because my friends the first time i went
on stage were like are you sure you want
to do this because i toured and i went
to houston it was the first time all my
friends
saw me in houston i go dude you're not
funny though what's gonna happen i go no
i'm funny on stage i'm just not funny
i'm a serious guy not serious but
i'm kind of just like mellow i'm chill
in real life but when on stage i don't
know i just love to tell stories and
things like that so
you know on stage i'm great but so
you're just really clever like you're
able to tell good stories in a funny way
and like come up with good jokes and
stuff absolutely when it's when it's
calculated but like off the hook that
maybe oh i'm terrible like uh what is
off the cuff yeah off the cuff yeah like
i do they invite me to do all these
shows where you got to think of stuff
real quick and i'm terrible really yeah
but there's a lot of people that like
that i'm more of a i don't write
anything but i'm more of
here's a whole story about something
that happened like i have a whole story
about me almost dying from covey like i
got that big story in my special that's
out right now and it's a 12-minute story
but it's funny because i thought it
through and i know the beats and all
that stuff how does that work when
you're writing out a script for this how
do you insert the jokes in a way that
you wouldn't be able to do like on the
cough i don't write a script it's i tell
a real story and then heighten it joe
coy he's a big comedian right now he was
my mentor and he goes if you ever sit
down to write a joke stop sit down write
a real story and heighten it so i just
tell real stories and that's why i never
write down stuff
because i know the story is true and i
know all the beats to it then i just got
to find the funny parts in the story and
just heighten those you know how do you
find the funny parts though like let's
say you're telling a serious story about
you almost dying from kovac yeah at what
point are you like hey i've gotta slip a
joke right there okay well well i like
to get a laugh every 20-30 seconds so
for instance this really happened and
it's not even joke form but it's just
funny when i told her on stage when uh
the paramedic put on um
you know they gave me oxygen and they
told me to say goodbye to my family so
my wife is holding my son at the door
and there's a window separating i got
covered i can't touch him so i put my
hand on the window by my son and i'm
gasprayer like
and my son puts his hand on top of my
hand looks at me and goes
i was not expecting a joke there
is funny and then of course a heightened
where i'm like this little dude making
fun of me man
but the comedian is like his timing is
incredible so it's kind of like i find
those moments i talk about how the
doctor tested every drug on me and i
have jokes about that how they told me i
was the first patient in l.a with
covenant i had jokes about that so
i just take a real life situation if
something happens or if i make somebody
laugh i go okay what made him laugh and
i go back and then kind of right around
that when did you realize you had a
talent for that
i guess when i was on chelsea lately her
show was really big i was a reporter on
the show because i worked for e so i
would interview celebrities and then
once we got to
uh
once i got to know all the comedians joe
coy was like you're really funny you
remind me of myself you should try stand
up and i tried it and in miami improv
and the first time i went on i did 15
minutes and that's a long time for your
first time ever going on and i fell in
love with it i got off stage called my
mom and said this is what i was born to
do and my mom was like really you know
because you're not funny basically you
know that's how they they don't they've
never seen me as that but on stage it's
just something different it's fun now
how do you improvise on stage if you're
not funny in person how do you shift to
character if like let's say something
happens and you have to stop some crowd
work or something yeah crowd work i'm
terrible at like i know what i'm like i
know what i want to accomplish i know
how to make people a part of my show but
i know exactly where to go it's going
yeah where there are some comedians that
can just my friends like i think you saw
one of them at mad apple harrison
greenbox
he can just riff with the crowd like
that's what he specializes yeah you know
and like i've known him for 10 years and
he's so amazing at that and he's a great
storyteller and he's a great comic but
he's more of a
boom but he's hitting you with jokes
fast yeah i'm more of like so this
happened to me today and i'll take you
through a story and you'll get
emotionally attached to it and then i'll
give you a joke about so he's a
different style of comedian you know but
he's a crowdwork comedian and i love
those joe coy was a crowdwork comedian
in bag is a crowdwork comedian me i kind
of
i know exactly where i'm gonna get you
i'll i'll go to you and say oh and ask
you a question but i know where i'm
going yeah you know what i mean
so you guys may have noticed that ftx
has sponsored this podcast for a while
now and they've helped us out a ton and
if you guys want to help us out and
support this podcast it would really
mean a lot if you guys could go check
out ftx they're linked down below
because they support us which then
allows us to do what we do and help
entertain you guys yeah they're a great
cryptocurrency brokerage i've been using
them for a while now and i really like
the fact that uh unlike other exchanges
which charge you high fees their fees
are significantly lower than just about
all of the major competitors for them
and they're just a really easy platform
it's so simple just to go and type in
what you want how much of it you want
how often you want to buy it and then
you just swipe right and you're done
this allows you to dollar cost average
into the markets on a regular basis
without having to worry about it or
think about or get too emotional on the
markets when it comes to myself i have a
very long-term outlook with uh when it
comes to cryptocurrency and so for me i
enjoy setting something up where i don't
even have to think about it and i know
it just gets done at a price that is
more affordable than a lot of the other
top brokerages ftx recently spent 250
million dollars expanding its equity
trading infrastructure to ensure that
even their stock trades don't have fees
and not only that but they're also
running a promotion right now where you
can get up to 100 in free crypto when
you trade 10 or more on the platform so
you can get free crypto you can trade
without fees on nfts and all crypto on
the platform and they're the best
exchange out there so you guys should
definitely check them out with that link
down below description with ftx thank
you so much ftx and now back to the
podcast so let's go through a little bit
of the story to provide some context to
viewers because it sounds pretty crazy
when you say like oh you were
interviewing celebrities at e and then
you won an america's got talent and
performed in front of like no crowd or
whatever alex said and then you know now
you're a touring comedian can you walk
us through like where you started and
how you got to where you are now so i
started on radio i was a radio dj i had
a huge show on radio in miami i was on
y100 and the show did so well
and i never did tv before so the
president from what i understand the
president of e at the time was in town
his name was ted harbor and he heard my
radio show because his daughter was
thinking of going to the university of
miami
and he heard me interview i interviewed
nick lachey when he just broke up with
jessica simpson that's how long it was
and he goes nobody could get that
interview and this kid got it how did he
do that and it was a great interview so
he goes back his casting people come out
to meet with me they offered me a job on
tv never been on tv
never wanted to be on tv and i said no
for like six months because i love radio
i was like why would i want to be on tv
because i gotta move and your first tv
contract to ever give you
they can let you go every three months
but you can't leave and i built up this
huge show in miami i was like i'm not
going to leave where y'all can fire me
in three months so
finally six months went by where i said
no and they called me and go okay what
can we do to get you i go let me keep my
radio show build me a radio studio i'm
like they're never going to do that so
they built me a radio studio and i was
right across from ryan seacrest
so ryan seacrest was across the hall
this is when american idol was huge and
i was like
and when you see somebody from afar
you're like i could never be that and
then when i moved here and he was pat i
knew him he would pass me every day go
what's up man it makes it a reality like
oh i can do what that guy does you know
it may take longer to get to where he is
but i can do that and that's how i kind
of all took off and then they put me on
tv and it just kind of took off from
there i was on the kardashians i did um
chelsea lately and i was at e when it
was huge and then i and then i worked
for extra
insider et uh access hollywood so i
worked for all those shows and i would
just my specialty was interviewing
people like celebrities yeah who were
some notable people that you had
interviewed well
i mean tom cruise
tom hanks is phenomenal tom cruise is
awesome will smith before all the
trouble and i don't care what people say
about him the nicest guy you will ever
meet i know he had a breakdown on stage
or i don't know what he was going
through always treated me with respect
was so nice to everyone and he uh yeah
he messed up yeah you keep his name out
of our pockets
[Laughter]
he's trying to try he uh
he's always been great but then i mean
the rock kevin hart will ferrell i mean
just about
there's not one person that you could
think of that's you know has a big
career that i have an interview leonardo
dicaprio amazing so
i interviewed him and
it was what was the movie um
uh god what was it called started with
it d i can't remember the django no no
actually well i've interviewed him for
that one but it was this
no it was the one that was it didn't
start with a d inception no it was the
fancy one bos lerman did it i think oh
great gatsby yes so we were at the great
gatsby interviewing him and man let me
tell you the dude it's so interesting
interviewing people like him because you
sit down you go i'm interviewing a
legend i mean he's not one
but when it's all said and done he's a
legend and that's where i get kind of
like stoked about it because you're
interviewing a person that when history
is done and acting he's going to be a
legend and he's great he's nice you know
i mean he's not like going to make you
laugh or anything he's a serious actor
where like a ben stiller or chris rock
or kevin hart they'll make you laugh
during the interview he's all about the
work you know what i mean i mean you'll
have cute moments with them but it's not
like you're breaking
anything
do you come up with your own questions
to ask or are there pre-set questions
that they know ahead of time well this
is why i got out of it because there are
some things they want you to ask and
it's your job to ask but you can ruin
relationships you could piss off actors
and because you got to ask about their
personal lives because really honestly
nobody gives about the movie nobody
cares about your movie you know really
honestly nobody maybe top gun
yeah they care about it but they don't
care about the shots and they don't care
about oh so how long were you in the
plane shooting they don't care tom
cruise who are you dating now what's up
with you and you like that's what they
care about yeah and if publicists don't
say because when you get there
publicists give you guidelines they go
you can ask you can't ask about x
but if a publicist doesn't say that you
have to ask because your
your boss will call what they didn't say
give you regulations you so you could
ask why didn't you and i just got tired
of i don't care about your personal life
i don't even care about your movie you
know i just do this because i love
interviewing people and then it got to
it got to a point where it was just i
would think of the fun questions and
then they would have the gossipy
questions the ones that's on the front
page of magazines and that sucks to be
that guy that breaks the story about
somebody's
past relationship or if somebody died in
their life or something like that you
know so what was like a question that
you asked where it really didn't go over
well
so
anna what was her name uh anna ferris no
anne hathaway yes
how do you do that jack jingle
so
she was in rio it was it was a cartoon
called rio too right this is when kanye
west and uh
kim kardashian were on uh like vanity
fair one of these big magazines it's the
lady that wears the glasses that devil
wears prada
uh meryl streep no yeah but she was
playing this lady
i don't know
what that was that lady jack
double glasses
she has the big butt she's like huge she
does the mat and it was the first time
they ever put like a reality star in the
industry was like oh this the magazine
is going downhill but anne hathaway was
on the magazine
so my boss was like you gotta get her to
talk about kanye west
and kim kardashian on the magazine and
in my mind i'm going that's the dumbest
girl who cares her thought just because
she was on the magazine doesn't mean she
cares about that it didn't have anything
to do with it nothing yeah that's not
that's like me asking y'all about a
person that podcasts when y'all podcast
he's like well what do you think like
you're like i don't even know them why
would i care
i asked her that question which was
really nice so you had to climb you had
to kind of walk up to this platform
where she was and i'm walking down the
platform and can i curse on this yeah
okay she goes
why the [ __ ] would he ask me that
question when i don't give a [ __ ] about
the kardashians i don't give a [ __ ]
who
cares who's on a magazine blah blah blah
blah blah blah and i got really angry
and i was about to go back up and then i
go no
she's right because that's what i said
to my boss before she he made me ask why
did you defend yourself because it she
was right
like so why don't you say like oh i
agree like well because i was already
down she was on a platform so i was
walking down she thought i was already
down but i was midway did she think you
could hear her she had no idea
so she was just like blasting me and
then the problem is her publicist calls
our boss and we never ran it so i asked
this stupid question for nothing and i
got tired of doing that you know i
thought they were going to twist to be
like anne hathaway doesn't care about
kim kardashian and kanye west i mean
they couldn't yeah that's what i'm
saying and they would twist it but
they're not going to give you the
footage because when you do a junket
they keep all the footage and if they
say it's okay they give you the footage
they wouldn't give me that they didn't
give it to our team
so we couldn't run it and that's like so
you ruin a relationship a future
relationship to interview somebody
because
just like i would imagine
you know finance or whatever you do it's
all about contacts and if nobody wants
you to my contacts were celebrities and
if nobody wanted me to interview them
i'd lose my job
and so you could scratch anne hathaway
off the list you know and uh after a
couple of those
so you were worried about like damaging
yourself to the point where you've
ruined connections with people in
connections with publicist
because now you're that guy yeah you
become that guy oh when he he he's not
gonna do a fun interview he's gonna do a
fun but then he's gonna ask
crappy questions and make the celebrity
mad do we wanna really put him in a room
with brad pitt or angelina jolie when
he's gonna be that guy i became like for
a little bit i was that guy but i worked
for the biggest entertainment outlet so
they had to take me anyway and the
publicist like you could just feel it i
was at and you and that sticks with you
no matter where you go even when you're
not working i would go i lived in l.a i
would go to places where celebrities
were and you could see them kind of like
oh is he going to
rat on really they'd notice you and just
like recoil and yeah
i'm very i have a look to me when i walk
in the room
[Laughter]
no but they they would call yeah because
they knew
that oh if i do something this guy could
report it on tv and i hated that feeling
i had that moment with rihanna where
she was like freaking out i was in this
room we were in this vip thing it was
only about 20 people it's backstage at a
concert and
you know i could tell you could just
feel it she was like i saw i walked in i
could see her just kind of roll our eyes
and literally i went up to her go yo i'm
not
i'm not here for that you know and i
just got sick of being yeah that guy
where it also it wasn't my dream to
interview these people my dream is to
have my own podcast interview people
where i own everything and i wanted
things to
you know i was living everybody else's
dream it's interesting to interview
everybody and they're living out your
dream and this is not your dream at all
and then that's why i said okay i
started comedy let me go on agt
uh
there was no audience they called me the
night before like do you want to wait
till next year and i go no
i'll just do it and then i did the first
episode and then i got kovit almost died
and then that was like
so i was sick the whole time it took me
10 months to get well so i was sick
during the second round and then
i wasn't i didn't move forward and it
was this
weird situation but it's more about now
moving forward for me betting on
yourself
and i never really did that before yeah
because
my job was not to bet on myself it was
being told what to ask
going to somebody hearing about their
life dreams and then going back and go
oh i got your question like that was the
big deal if i asked got a great answer
to a question my they wanted you know
and it's like
like do you ever keep in contact with
those celebrities after you interview
them like maybe you hit it off and
you're just like hey let's hang out
sometime you know what i i've never been
that guy really i mean i have my phone
is loaded with celebrity names but i've
just never been that guy because i i
always want to be the guy when i do go
to a celebrity it's for they're not ever
going to say oh i was partying with that
guy and i don't want him to work i don't
want to work with that guy i always want
to keep a certain image with people that
when i do call they're like okay let me
listen because he's never asked me for
anything this must be serious like for
instance the rock i love the rock and
it's a thing where if i ever call the
rock
you know hopefully it'll pick up and
it'll be like okay he never reaches out
what's the deal michael you've always
treated me well impressed i've treated
you well what
what project do you have you know so
that's that's the kind of situation i
want to be in with these celebrities
wouldn't it be better though to get
buddy buddy with the rock and just say
like hey let's if he's free
hang out go to the gym
have you seen that dude
i don't i don't really and here's the
thing it's very interesting i don't like
people
like i i mean i love performing i love
doing my thing but i'm not a big hanger
outer like i have my close friends but
they're all in houston so i mean i'll do
poker night and things like that but me
going out like i'm married with two kids
i don't go out anymore i like i i gotta
watch these kids my wife is so awesome
so that's my life right now and since i
travel so much i gotta when i'm in town
it's kind of just that got it i know i
sound like this boring married guy but
it's crazy you know it's it's it's a
very exciting life yeah because we get
to do a lot of stuff but it's also you
know it's like once you're at home with
kids it's
that's your focus you know i figure we
should mention because i don't think we
mentioned this before but you guys are
neighbors yes yeah that's how this whole
thing like occurred and how you you know
you met each other yeah how was it i was
walking to the gym and i think i saw you
unpacking some stuff and i wanted to be
neighborly and go say hi
he introduced himself to me and i was
and i was like oh that's awesome so a
couple days later um you know i i
knocked on your door
and just said hi and asked had some
questions about because i knew you were
in the podcast world and just had some
questions and then it kind of just went
for you and automatically invited me to
poker night oh yeah that's right yeah
make it because i was performing but
it's it's awesome the more you learn
about where we just moved how it's just
phenomenal first of all i i when i look
back on like any time i land in la or go
back
i want to get out because i love the
space here i love it i just love the
lifestyle i love performing here i love
flying out of here for my job it's the
best yeah i gotta ask
why did you leave california gotta get
that little audio clip in there oh yeah
so i left california because
we lived in studio city
and after covet after i beat it i was
walking my son in our neighborhood and a
homeless person like we lived in a
really nice neighborhood threw something
at my son and he was three so that's
when i told my wife and she she said
let's go visit my parents in vegas
and
we fell in love with it rented something
for two years so they built our house
here and then just moved in like two
months ago or three months ago and man
talk about a difference everything's
easier out here everything's cheaper out
here people don't care what you do you
know the hard thing to me personally
about l.a
is i tell people is if everybody
everybody does the same thing if you're
in my industry and you live around and
you talk to those people all the time
it's almost like if everybody worked in
the same restaurant and everybody wanted
to be the general manager of that
restaurant so every conversation is like
oh who's on fries who's on the cashier
who's on so it's like what audition
what'd you do what'd you do today what'd
you do so that's a heaviness
that that's on you and once i moved here
after i do an audition i won't get asked
by anyone
nobody cares about my audition nobody
cares about anything and that's what i
love about vegas you know like people
it's the first time in a long time they
talk to you about your they ask you
about your kids your family and it's
pretty cool and like our neighborhood
this neighborhood is like great people
and like
my kids have met so many other kids and
the parents are like there's some
amazing people that live in this
neighborhood and i'm meeting all of them
and it's like
like this is a hot spot you know for
talent for
connections for everything what else
have you met here because i i've never
introduced myself ever to the neighbors
in l.a who else do you want me to say
yeah sure the governor lives like three
houses away really the guy yes
the governor
that he lived in this i don't know he
lives like right up the street really
the governor yeah i see him at the gym
he's at the gym wait which one is he
because i go to the gym huh
well yeah he goes at like 5am oh yeah
definitely
certainly not yeah what in whether
you're democrat or republican sysolak
he he lives here like i definitely have
not seen him yeah the guy that created
the dune video game lives here right up
the street really oh dude he's a massive
like see the guy with the corvette i
always see he lives if you were to go
straight up from your house
the set where they built all that stuff
in the front of their house yeah yeah he
lives right so he's created all these
electric companies and he sells them i
mean it's it's it's crazy like football
players basketball players for the
raiders for uh the hockey team live here
that's nuts yeah and because you know
the great thing is i meet them because
we all have kids you know so i think
that's what gets me out more than you is
because our kids play with their kids
and it's all this
it's and it's you're saying kids are
good for networking
and i think that's the most important
thing you're going to learn on this
podcast for this neighborhood kids in
vegas are great for networking before
the podcast we were talking about like
how people put certain like societal or
like restrictions on what comedians can
or can't say and you being a comedian i
know this is kind of like a
controversial
and debatable topic what do you think
about comedians making jokes that maybe
could be seen as like too far or feel
like they can't be too edgy or anything
and are we moving in that direction no i
don't think we are i think certain
people are
here's the problem today is a very small
group
can make a lot of noise and get people
canceled you know because most people
don't care what other people say they
just they live their lives you know and
that's one thing when i lived in l.a
it's very left so all you hear is that
oh
you get really like used to hearing one
side and then when you move here where
it's 50 50 you're like oh people don't
really care you know you i people like
oh when you move to vegas oh my god
people gonna go nuts they're gonna be
waving trump flags in front of your
house
no it's not like that so you learn that
it's just a very small group of people
that do that now there are certain
comedians that will push the envelope
you got dave chappelle talking about
transgender and he gets in a lot of
trouble for that
and i feel that it's interesting
comedians bigger comedians will always
say
nothing should ever stop you from saying
what you want to say the comedians that
are saying that
are loaded making 20 25 million dollars
a special right
people like me coming up
i
i watch what i say i always say what i
want to say but i'll try to find a less
offensive way to say it because i'm
still trying to come out
you know and so i think that's the
that's where we are the people that have
made it the bill birds the
the uh the dave chappelles the
sebastians the well jim gaffigan doesn't
push that line jim jeffries is one of my
personal friends like he will push it
because he doesn't care but now don't
you think that these people all made
their careers coming up by saying those
things and now that we've moved in a
direction that's against it they could
get away with it only because they're so
big
by doing that already is it is it
that we're more sensitive or more
involved see this is where i go back and
forth is if you watch eddie murphy's raw
and delirious
it's so out of out of tone for word i
mean he drops f word he's talking about
all kinds of things you could not talk
about today you know so i think
i think
he shouldn't apologize for that back
then because it was very acceptable back
you look at it today you go oh my god if
you've never seen raw deli go back and
watch that and it will blow you away is
that the one in the 80s
yeah i've seen clips he's hilarious
if you watch the whole special you'll be
like
whoa
like there's no way
no way
you could say that today you talk about
cancel nobody would put you on tv you
would be thrown out of the united states
of america probably if you said the
things he said in that special and he
apologized for it but to me you
shouldn't apologize for it because
you filled up movie theaters where
people wanted to see that you know and
it was acceptable at the time what what
people the cancer culture gets confused
with things were like when people have
to go back and apologize for things a
lot of times whether it was right or
wrong it was acceptable
you know i'm not saying
really getting super racial and just
being wrong at all periods of time what
i'm saying is certain words were
acceptable at a time it's not right
but at a time it was very acceptable you
know uh talking about certain
certain genders were okay at a time
today
it's kind of like okay
i'm gonna say this
but i know i can get backlash so now
it's on the comic
is it right he's gonna get backlash
it depends what he says you know i i
believe in freedom of speech and what
people forget is
if i say something to you
and you don't like it
you have the freedom of speech to go
complain
so people always take the other side out
of the equation they go like when you
hear news anchors they're trying to
cancel me it's like no you said what you
had to say now these other people are
saying what they have to say
you know so if you look at it that way
cancel culture
is normal because that is it because it
seems like a new thing i don't remember
this being a thing like six years ago
because there was no 24-hour news there
was no social media somebody somebody if
it took work to cancel somebody nobody
would do it it take it's harder for me
to cancel my gym membership than to
cancel a person like literally you have
to write a letter to your gym you have
to bring it they have to meet with an
advisor advisor chance to keep you to
stay you said no they're like all right
well and they try to work out the exit
deal this
10 seconds
if it catches fire the person gets
canceled if not no big deal they move on
don't you think that's dangerous though
terrible yeah it's terrible but also as
a comedian
you can't stop what other people do
because now everybody has an opinion you
know you remember when you used to have
to actually know what you're talking
about you remember those things i don't
remember yeah
no but if you specialize in finances
yeah specialize in comedy like these
people work years for people to trust
them to even get on tv now you hold up
your phone you're an expert like when
people when people go i do my own
research that's very dangerous
especially about medical stuff like no
talk to a doctor that actually does it
as a profession i actually went to
school for it but you have people just
googling
whatever coronavirus reading what they
want to read
and then that's what they go with and
then they get mad if you don't agree
with it right so i recently went to a
bruno mars concert and they took away
all our phones and i heard some
comedians are doing this too and you
have to so yeah i was going to ask you
so you agree with this and if so why a
hundred percent your seller not here but
in new york they take away everybody's
phones they put them in a green bag and
you gotta tap it to leave because
this is what frustrates me when you're
on stage as a comedian when i'm at the
comedy seller tonight what i'm saying on
stage is not the final product but
you're judging what i say like it's the
final project pro a product like my
special that's out right now that's the
final product you know so it's kind of
like me going to a writer that writes
all these negative stories about
comedians
turning in their first draft
and going this is your first well no i
got to correct all the mistakes and then
an editor has to read it and then he
sends it back to me and then i got to do
it again i got to rewrite some of the
stuff but comics don't get that leniency
it's kind of whatever you say it's done
this is what you think it's like no
that's why we go up in practice because
you could say anything and somebody now
you can say anything and people take it
wrong you know i have a joke about my
son
and my daughter and i go my son uh
bumped my daughter once right you know
and she was playing with a toy and i got
really angry and then i make a quick
joke and go but my daughter could hit my
son in the face with a brick and i'd be
like oh good job you know because it
just shows the mother the father thing
versus the mother and son people are
like this right after johnny devin like
this the nicest joke i'm the nicest
human and they're like you're teaching
sexism your son's gonna beat women
your your girl's gonna beat up men like
they're going bonkers about it like like
this why do they even show up to the
comedy thing no it's on youtube so it's
oh it's just reposted
it's the youtube comments it's the
youtube comments
the comments like people go and i'm
never like to be honest with you my
youtube when i my special came out three
months ago i had three thousand people
on youtube like i it was a dumping
ground i never even i never looked at it
and then they go you should really put
together your youtube if you're gonna
put out special so for me i put out the
special and then three months later you
know i've gone from 30 000 views for a
channel like for the eight years to now
in just three months i got 120 000
people and over 37 million so for me
that's great because i never had
anything before but i got to get used to
just random people getting really pissed
off
about i'm not used to that you know it's
just they really get upset and i'm not
even a cancelled type of comic but to
see people overreact
about a joke about my son and daughter
it's a joke but they take it as well you
could use that as content 100 percent
and i am from an expert that's going to
read
some of the comments and let them know
how freaking ridiculous they are and how
dumb they are that's good yeah i like
that yeah and i'm getting so much
material from that i mean these people
you know what's amazing to me that
people have time to write paragraphs and
paragraphs to you on a comment who does
that do you have no life i mean i've
done that before
not negative
not negative it's all never negative
stuff but like sometimes i'm really deep
involved in the video and i just want to
like i've written long long things too
but it's usually no it's in response to
someone saying like some sort of
critique to me and i try to like
understand what they're saying and then
i give them a nice you know a well
thought out message back but why you
don't even know these people because i i
don't know i'm sensitive maybe i don't
yeah but the thing is your response is
public so even if you don't know them
other people who see that comment will
see your response because you're talking
to hundreds or thousands if one person
has like they have a misread on what you
said or whatever and then they comment
about it other people can see that and
just latch on to that but if you don't
respond and defend yourself then
that will happen and it will be like an
echo chamber but if you do respond
people will see your response be like
you know that's reasonable and then not
like oh i get that i responded i go this
is a joke and i said first of all my
daughter is one she can be funny
if if you commented back my daughter
will beat up your daughter
yeah so that's the thing is like i found
humor like when people say i don't like
technology oh you know me neither you
know you'd write cute stuff like that
but it's just amazing like when people
just sit down and just write and write
and write
but it's a new thing for me on youtube
you know yeah what was it i was
listening to a podcast um
and uh they mentioned something about
how the news cycle changes completely
every 36 hours yes and so 36 hours from
now
unless there's an update like no one's
gonna care anymore and people stop
running the story and that is true
because
24-hour news changed the whole game i i
i'm older than y'all but i was in the
day when
there was you waited till seven o'clock
to hear your news and whatever they said
that night that was it
that was the news and they would run one
story for a month if it was a big story
now news asks outlets
hype up stories so much and put all
these experts on that will disagree with
what they say and fight with other
people and that's what it's become just
opinions you know and they got to do
that to keep people interested because
if a news anchor just comes up and tells
you the facts you're like okay so what
am i going to do with that i want to
hear people argue about that you know
and that's where we are so
and what proves what you just said
there's presidents that'll do stupid
things and say crazy things and 36 hours
later they could say something else and
you totally would forget about the thing
they said before you know so there's
ways to take advantage of it too if you
are that character you know where you
don't care and you're going to say
whatever you want to say they'll forget
about you you know you're you're one
natural disaster or one hurricane or
anything away something bad happening
from people totally forgetting yeah
about the dumb thing you did do you have
a review process for your jokes like do
you do you have a person who maybe says
hey michael not a good idea soften this
up a little bit do you have like someone
my wife yeah
kinda
you know and i have a couple comics that
travel with me and we always throw stuff
off each other like my wife is very
sensitive the topic matters so my last
special i didn't let her see it until i
shot it and then
my family my mom dad they they tried to
cancel me so i'm not worried about it
oh yeah what happened now we gotta hear
it you know what i i had a joke where
it's not me saying it but i called my
wife a bee in it but i don't mean it
wasn't me i said the joke is i survived
covet i'm going through that and i go my
wife is taking care of my kids i'm
hearing my son ask where daddy is and
i'm getting breakfast lunch and dinner
delivered to my room and then the crowd
starts live and i go man covered ain't
that bad i feel like a husband in the
50s now i said i feel like i'm like get
those kids away from me it was my dinner
you know
no you're not calling him yeah
oh my god
but but i get i get what you know what i
mean i'm not if i was 50 like if i was
in the 50s making fun of these i'm
making fun of what they call women but
my wife didn't hear it like that she was
like oh you called me a [ __ ] and then
my mom lit watched my first special
four years ago and she was there and we
watched it together
now that all these reels are coming out
people are making rails yeah and in one
of those i called her a [ __ ] but it
wasn't it wasn't me again similar
similar situation you know and then so
you gotta and then the biggest mistake i
made in this comedy special my wife told
me not to do it yeah
and i did it i called my kid
uh
a [ __ ]
what's the
no but i shouldn't that alone's enough
for alex justin all right yeah it's
laughing alex is laughing
it's funny in this in the bit
but i had a clean version where i don't
say that and i was like man [ __ ]
is so funny dude but i was like now that
i watch it i go what if my son gets old
he exists my dad called me [ __ ]
i think he i don't think he's gonna care
hopefully he does it but i didn't but i
guess my thing is i didn't have to say
it because i could i kind of said this
this little
like it goes uh it was when after he
touches the window
and i go this little [ __ ] making
fun of me man [ __ ] you dude yeah and
then i go but the comedian says his time
is incredible i could have said
i had a version that worked just as the
last sort of thing i go this little dude
is making fun of me because the joke is
the
thing and then i go this little dude is
making fun of me screw you dude but the
comment so i had the clown
but but that's not as it doesn't have
the same punch like yeah it's showing
that like you know he's not your kid
it's like disassociating now because i'm
not making fun of him i mean would you
go talk to my wife and let her know
right two houses just yeah
and that's the thing and then you worry
about oh if my wife is like that she
must have heard outside noise from other
people that's saying he called you a
[ __ ] in this special
did she
i don't think okay i feel like
yeah but i didn't call her that i was
like if this person in the 50s no i i
get it i get it but you get it right
yeah like if you say this little kid is
making fun of me i feel like that comes
off as even more genuine as though like
there's tension between you and your son
but if you disassociate you your
relationship from this like you know the
silliness of the situation yeah by
calling it mf yeah i mean then it's like
it's completely detaching and you're
just talking about this i find the
extremes so much funnier like you have
to take it to like that where it's it's
it's like obvious it's so obvious but
it's so extreme so like that to me is
really humor lies so that's the thing i
was watching my special back i had both
versions and i go man my [ __ ]
just hits it does it mean
you could have done it the other way and
got ninety percent but no no it was like
more than 76 yeah when you say the mf
when you say this little guy they're
like
yeah
that's i i agree with you on that you
know so it's it's i'm not even worried
about getting cancer from the outside
i'm worried about like now i have this
new joke i'm working on for my next
special where it talks about how women
can't make men great i mean how men
can't make women great but then i get to
the point where i talk about women
how you make us great but you drive as
[ __ ] crazy right so now
i'm kind of like okay what can i talk
about what how can i dance this line
where my wife's not gonna get offended
because now obviously i'm talking about
that size yeah you know what i mean this
is i'm talking in real time now so
that's where i'm like for my wife i'm
like okay you know like my wife the
thing i'm talking about now is my wife
loves to set traps for me and every
woman does in a relationship they will
ask you questions where both answers are
wrong no matter what you answer it's
wrong my wife was like miss wyoming blah
blah blah so all her friends are like
like beauty miss usa's miss universes
that's all her friends right
and when we lived in l.a they would come
to the house and they would look at the
screen and go oh my gosh she's beautiful
any answer i say is wrong if i say she's
beautiful you're like oh you think
another woman is beautiful
if i go she's ugly like oh he's lying
he's lying
so like those so those are the elements
i'm trying to beat out now like what
or people updated in the past but i
don't like to talk about people updating
so it's basically my wife what she does
to drive me crazy you know like when you
first get when you first uh start dating
when they say your name is sexy then
when you get married about after seven
years when they say your name you know
you're about to do something you know
like at the beginning it's like michael
you're like
you're about to get it up and later when
they say it like after years ago they go
michael i was like what i gotta do what
is it now
it's funny yeah
that's funny yeah but you got to
remember there's a real woman attached
to that in real time you know so now
here's the thing can you make up stories
so that she doesn't feel like you're
you're talking about your own
relationship no i'd never make up
stories what i will do is put it in
other people's words like i i
yeah i will do that
i don't want to say you almost got in
trouble right now that's true
that's trash here
as other people but if you guys are
watching based on a true story
i have a heart out because i got booked
on a tv show so and they're going over
the final and i'm very happy about it so
they said they're gonna call like any
second so that's why i gotta bounce but
it's uh
this has been awesome yeah thank you so
much no no but we could keep this going
longer but you know what another time
and then yeah next time we won't get
into the house thing we can keep it i
want to hear more about your wife
and he wants to talk
though yeah dude that's awesome yeah
thanks that's awesome yeah i could start
making jokes too no no no no jokes no
i'm kidding that was a joke just wait oh
my god we'll talk but it's it's awesome
yeah
just let her do everything if she's into
weddings or whatever if she's into that
like my wife was really big in the
wedding
no matter they'll ask you for your
opinion they don't want it just be
supportive like you'll they'll be like
do you like this color or this color and
you'll pick a color and they'll be like
oh i don't like that i like this one
you're like okay that's what i told him
yeah and he said and he said he will
stand his ground wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait you can oh for the wet
now i got to defend myself honestly
there are certain things that i feel
like i i would be inauthentic to myself
if i back down there are other things
that uh
you know i'm totally fine with whatever
macey wants uh i'm good with that like
for for a wedding for example if you
don't care about it
or if i'm indifferent there are certain
things that i i'm really passionate
about and i feel like i will stand up
for those things and other things that i
care more about uh you know macy being
happy for a wedding i think this is
about
her
and
you know creating
that that day that she's always wanted
um for me
it's uh
you know i i care more about her being
happy in that moment
so if she's like
between i'm not talking about the
wedding no what are you doing i was just
talking in in general yeah when we were
at the gym it was funny ask graham the
question like you know are there certain
things that you that you stand for where
if macy did something that you
necessarily didn't agree with but it
wasn't the most important thing you know
do you stand your ground or do you ever
give it to macy and just say you know
what i'll let you have this one and then
you said no i will not not be myself
yeah i mean that's kind of the truth
which i mean i don't even know if
there's necessarily a right and wrong
for this but sometimes for me personally
in my relationships i like to maybe take
some things to the chin and maybe step
outside of
go outside of like what i truly believe
and just in order to avoid an argument
which i know sounds extremely con which
i know sounds extremely unhealthy yeah
to like bottle that stuff in but in my
opinion certain times you could do like
a costume analysis and say bottomland
causes this much damage but also the
potential argument causes this you know
something interesting
that i've worked on i'll be personal
here that's something i really worked on
uh
in the very beginning i took that
approach and i bottled things up and i
think it's not worth it it's not worth
it i did the same sort of risk versus
reward within a few months it got to a
point where things were
just bottling up and i just wasn't happy
and i got really good at being honest
and open and and sharing my thoughts and
if macey will ask me a question
um instead of either skirting the issue
or just nah i'm not bothered uh it's
i'll be completely honest so if she ever
asked me something like graham did uh
are you upset right now i'll just flat
out say yes um and why and i feel so
much better about it and i think our
communication is so much better uh that
does mean of course that there is
some conflict if there is something that
you know either we disagree with or
you know worth it
very little to do the same thing grim
yeah yeah there's very little that
is not worth it um it's just you know on
a magnitude of one to ten usually it's
minor stuff um
it's stupid stuff too i mean really
stupid but uh i just feel better about
sharing my true thoughts and if we
disagree we'll talk about it but that
sounds that sounds healthy and i'm sure
that there's a healthy balance on both
sides of like you know maybe i'll just
avoid this one because you got to pick
your battles and then other things maybe
where it matters a lot more to you then
you know you could choose to engage in
yeah sure there are some things for me
where it's you know let's just say i'm
um
frustrated or something like that
there's certain things for me or where i
know internally not even worth bringing
up like i'll be totally fine uh it's not
worth discussing but
anything that it is of any significance
for me
i'll always be honest i think you gotta
rephrase it jack i don't think you can
you know be like yeah you know not worth
it you gotta be you know you i think the
way to phrase it is like you gotta
really look at
the difference that you're having and
really think like is this really
important in life and like completely
let it go versus like
bottling it up as like graham was saying
in the beginning um because sometimes
when i think about those little things
it's like yeah really doesn't matter
let's get over it and then that's that's
basically what it is yeah yeah i don't
mean bottling it up i just mean just
like you know what letting it slide no
because for me
not letting it slide jack that's worse
no for sure like you're saying that
that's bad no but
i personally if i accept that i am
letting something go it doesn't bottle
up for me nor does it build resentment
and i i'm able to determine when if i do
bottle something up it will build
resentment versus when it won't you know
what i mean and obviously it's a net
negative if i do end up choosing the
building resentment side i don't know i
think our communications got a lot
better
for
both sides uh you know
and and me being more open is something
i've really worked on and like trying to
uh hear another person's side in general
i do remember that actually in the
beginning of the relationship how you
kept on like like i could see it on a
personal side where like you know like
obviously there's there's something that
bugged you or whatever you're like yeah
you know don't worry about it because
you're like avoiding the arguments so
and it does seem a lot you know
healthier whatever now yeah or whatever
all right well anyway
where'd michael go so guys michael had a
call because he's going on a show so he
had to leave and we are extremely
grateful that he came on the iced coffee
hour thank you guys so much for tuning
in we have a patreon link down below
jack tell us about the uh the patreon
what what happened you just completely
redid it so yeah we restructured the
entire patreon and uh
we changed the perks around and i think
it's really cool let us know what you
guys think down below we got some really
really cool and interesting ideas i
think you guys will really like yeah so
check it out to see what those are and i
also told jack it's a jacket too
expensive and he lowered the price that
is the
exact opposite of what the truth is that
is
exactly what's the truth tell us so
that's no no no okay with that said guys
thank you so much for watching yeah just
make sure to get your free stuff down
below in the description when you sign
up for public keys at the gram check out
michael check out my instagram jls
s-e-l-b-y also big big thank you to our
sponsors of this episode and with that
said you guys until next time next time
you